a wallet that looks like a matchbook and
edible spray paint it's episode 21 the
mints that come in this spam ten
actually taste like cinnamon but this
lip balm tastes like Lucky Charms
question what's warmer than a sweater
and a mug a hot chocolate
answer a mug wearing a sweater keep your
hands equally warm with predator and
prey mittens one hands a cat the others
a dog one's a frog one's a fly ones an
owl and the other is a mouse or use
Tati's they let you get touchy with your
touchscreen without removing your gloves
of course all of these gloves will cover
up your awesome ring with the stones sec
upside down making it a killer ring or
this ring with the hidden diamond
generate also has synthetic leather bags
that look like envelopes wing rings and
shirts with special stripes you can wipe
your glasses with but let's talk about
molds that make your cookies into
moustaches or these cupcake pillows a
giant Ice Cream Sandwich pillow is also
fun and barbed wire toilet paper is
mainly just scary kisses are better but
hey this bath towel makes it look like
you're wearing a kilt so let's talk high
fashion and cover funny hats
stupid calm also offers this tiny peace
sign hat for your little dog and of
course a hat that looks like underwear
does this guy even know that his hat is
funny I also like their hands waving USA
Flags hat keep things patriotic with
these flag pants betta brand also
carries these dress pants that are
actually sweatpants now if you've mainly
made history wearing shirts use Urban
Outfitters t-shirt frames to preserve
those memories or design your own on
this t-shirt design notepad also a good
option this notepad then toast your good
taste with some bacon flavored soda
perfect for washing down a giant burrito
just kidding it's a protective wrap for
valuable camera lenses improve your view
with generate skyline blinds and improve
your bathroom with this real aquarium
sink a perfect companion to the I poop
toilet your iPhone will be fine if you
drop it in because you've waterproof
with Liquipel or you're busy looking
like an executive with the iPhone
handset converter now these puzzles are
shaped like Donuts pizza or coffee
but the world-record-holding largest
puzzle can be yours it has more than 32
thousand pieces and weighs over 37
pounds for a more daredevil ish
challenge play Russian roulette
with water balloons you never know when
the gun will pierce the balloon but for
a sweeter challenge bite the bullet
gives you a dozen delicious chocolates
shaped like bullets except one contains
a hidden dangerously hot pepper good
luck if your sweet tooth also likes
bling pick up some twinkles dental
jewelry made with a special adhesive
that only lets go when you want to
remove it clean the rest of your teeth
with some floss you pulled out of a
dog's butt and clean your body with
tetromino shaped soap behind your
Facebook styled shower curtain then
decorate your hair with these comic
inspired headbands and show it all off
in front of the paparazzi that you hired
for an hour at $100 a photographer this
company will send paparazzi to harass
you and make you look famous no matter
who you are if you get a boo-boo during
the whole process be sure you're caught
wearing a brand new question can you
identify which characters these eyes
belong to or their sonic you can play on
the site or you can grab the picture as
an art print speaking of posters here's
a map of the world made with what makes
it go round mustaches and here's a
fictional map made out of places made
famous and songs just take the highway
to hell after Heartbreak Hotel and
picnic in a chiku Park this artist on
etsy will make an incredible custom
stamp that actually looks just like you
now separate salt and pepper shakers are
fine but Fred makes this switch pick
what you want and shake your ear buds
can be superheroes and your ears can
also delight in wearing some handmade
Calvin and Hobbes earrings if Hobbes
means something more philosophical to
you pick up a Hobbes mug now how about a
free thing try nightsoil this is the
word for human poop that you steal from
outhouses latrines and cesspools at
night in order to use as free fertilizer
on your
it's a bad idea don't do it compost that
stuff first come on
but seriously here are some great iPhone
backgrounds that you can get for free
from a great loot site a rama
cuboctahedron has 26 faces which is also
the number of years old I am turning
today that's right
it's my birthday and you're all invited
to the party consider the comments
section the party and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]